turning to the war in Ukraine Russia
launched new attacks against the key
region overnight and shelled a key City
in the south of the country they are the
latest in a series of strikes that begin
with the wave of missile and drone
attacks on Monday Charlie dagda is in a
city near the front lines in southern
Ukraine Charlie good morning
good morning we are in the city of
zaparesia which has been the target of
Relentless Russian bombardment this is
the middle of a residential area with
apartments around us you can see some of
the destruction
from This ferocious barrage that took
place earlier we watched as they
retrieved another victim from beneath
the rubble in the past two weeks more
than 70 people have been killed here all
civilians there was a an attack on a
civilian Convoy just a couple of weeks
ago apartment blocks right downtown but
it really accelerated on Monday and that
barrage that spread across the entire
country there were more attacks
overnight Kamikaze drone strikes outside
of Kiev that set off air raid sirens and
sent people to the shelters once again
Nick alive a city that's also been
targeted was hit once again dropping a
five-story building these are exactly
the kind of attacks that president
zielinski is begging International help
for to help stop missile defense systems
to stop these missiles from raining down
in residential areas spreading death and
destruction and Terror Across the Nation
for CBS morning's Charlie dagada
zapparesia Ukraine